my name is Claus Marte I'm an ex-drug
Kingpin one of these people in the
lineup is a former undercover cop and
I'm going to sniff them out so where are
you from I grew up in Levittown so
you're like in the mobster gangster
field that's classified cops don't get
nervous you know you guys are confident
oh you're right the cops don't get
nervous I'm nervous so how many push-ups
you can do
that's a good push-up all right so the
real cop can you take a step forward and
take a bite of the donut
oh man that's the nervousness even the
cover cops are pretty confident I don't
know about you man I don't know about
your confidence level y'all there you go
police officer for 20 years I wasn't a
knock
I did work in Warren Squad working the
Warren Squad you're playing close I
worked in the detective squad yeah do
you mind yeah go ahead man he said look
he's munching on that